[Aplausos]
miles de personas salieron a las calles
de París en una jornada de protestas por
el aumento del coste de vida y lo que
los manifestantes consideran como una
inacción climática por parte del
gobierno la izquierda es la gran
protagonista de la jornada especialmente
líder de nubes yang quien intentó
capitalizar el descontento social que
reina en Francia gran éxito de la marcha
16 de octubre 140.000 personas se
movilizaron contra una vida costosa la
inacción climática y la reforma de las
pensiones
los manifestantes exigen el cumplimiento
de 5 puntos principales
jubilación a los 60 años actualmente en
Francia la edad para pensionarse es de
62 años y Emanuel maccom propone que la
edad necesaria sea de 64 o 65 años un
subsidio de autonomía de 1.100 euros
para los jóvenes de 16 a 25 años cuyas
familias tengan ingresos por debajo de
los 2000 euros
con el objetivo de facilitar su
inserción en el mundo laboral impuestos
a los beneficios extraordinarios de las
grandes corporaciones e impulsar
políticas ambientales basadas en la
utilización de energías renovables y el
modelo de bifurcación ecológica
llegómme hace parte del movimiento
chalecos amarillos critica el rol de las
empresas en la crisis que vive el país
es fácil para una empresa decir que sus
trabajadores ganan aproximadamente 9.000
euros cuando el promedio se basa en el
salario de los ejecutivos y el director
general pero el sueldo de la mayoría de
la gente se reduce a 1.500 euros de los
cuales 500 son para pagar la gasolina
las protestas se dan en medio de la
huelga de los dos principales sindicatos
de la importante empresa de refinería
Total energys que exige Un aumento de su
salario el Sindicato de trabajadores cgt
expresó que no comparte la totalidad de
las exigencias hechas hoy en las calles
y tendrá su propia movilización el
próximo 18 de octubre
el día en el que se espera que haya una
huelga general de sindicatos